well if you haven't heard we're in the
middle of a modern-day Gold Rush
bitcoin is quite the thing Mike on
Twitter says can you talk me off the
ledge bitcoin looks so tempting but I
know that get-rich-quick stuff hardly
ever works well I can tell you as
someone who has gotten rich quick and
then lost everything that it doesn't
work get-rich-quick doesn't so here's a
philosophical financial theological
principle for you proverbs says he who
hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished when you chase an easy buck a
quick dollar from the standpoint of you
will not go unpunished
it doesn't say 60% of time it doesn't
say 10% of time it says you're gonna get
punished now I don't know a form of
punishment there will be I have no idea
it could be simply the losing of the
money but people lose money chasing easy
money it's that simple
and every time you do that you show your
lack of emotional maturity now I've got
a friend who's worth probably 2030
million dollars and he's got he dropped
I don't know hundred thousand bucks or
whatever in the Bitcoin if he loses that
that's like you losing a biscuit you
just bought you buy a biscuit at
chick-fil-a and it fell out the car oh
well you know that's what it would mean
to him it would not change his life it's
a very small percentage of his world but
this is also a guy who plays blackjack
in Vegas and the roulette wheel none of
which I do I'm not mad at you if you do
those things I just do not get a
personal recreational thrill out of
losing money it's not enjoyable to me
I'm more conservative than that fiscally
conservative politically to but fiscally
financially conservative I don't like
lose money I've worked too hard for it
and losing it is not an inner
haiman item for me so I haven't gotten
caught up in the fantasy football
betting thing I haven't gotten caught up
in the the lottery thing I haven't
gotten caught up in the Bitcoin thing I
haven't gotten caught up in the poker is
a big deal everybody's playing poker now
so it's a black Recreational like my
grandmother played bridge people play
poker like that now I mean it's like a
big thing everybody's all the cool
people are playing it the Millennials
are all poker players it's it's like ice
own sport it's on ESPN like it's a sport
or something but it all comes down to
that there is an entertainment value a
rush that you get a sense of risk that
you get because there's real risks
they're losing money playing these games
and any time you hastens to be rich you
will not go unpunished now again I'm not
mad at you if you want to lose some
money and you think that's fun if you
want to quote roll the dice unquote
metaphorically or literally go ahead go
ahead
if you hit big and that's entertaining
to you or you lose it all and that's
entertaining to you you got the
entertainment value I've got a you know
relative that plays poker all the time
and it's very entertaining the hell
it's nothing tainting to me it stresses
me out I don't like to lose money plus
I'm a math nerd and I can't stand
something that's do with math unless I
win so it just drives me nuts so and
cards are definitely that so I'm not
against it morally I'm not against
ethically I'm not against it
theologically I just do not get
personally get a thrill out of you know
rolling dice and see if I make money
it's not it's not thrilling to me and
that probably because I lost everything
in my twenties not to start again and
money is just too hard to come by and I
don't want to do that that's a personal
thing now the philosophical thing though
is this anytime you're chasing ez money
you're gonna get bet
nice Bitcoin easy money well yeah it's
gone from 1,000 to 19,000 in 20 seconds
it's way up some of you if you cashed
out today would have done very very well
playing with Bitcoin and congratulations
I hope you make a bunch of money I hope
you make a bunch of money and I hope
your fantasy football team comes through
and you make a hundred thousand on that
that you put a thousand into I hope that
works out for you but as a philosophy of
running your portfolio don't do
something stupid like this thing right
here CNBC is reporting people are now
taking out mortgages to buy Bitcoin this
is a Bitcoin is in the mania phase this
article says which it is people have
lost their freakin minds but some people
even borrowing money to get in on the
action we've seen mortgages taken out
people to credit cards and equity lines
president North American securities
Administration Association says of
voluntary we're gonna miss is not
something a guy who's making $100,000 a
year who's got a mortgage and two kids
ought to be invested in this article
says agreed bitcoins been soaring all
year started out a thousand now it's
rocketing up over 19,000 on the coinbase
exchange last week you're on the mania
curve listen if oil was doing this if
oil went from a thousand to 19,000 would
you be going oh no but it's kind of cool
because it's technology so some of you
are you you're enamored by the fact that
this is technology
it's not even technology its
cryptocurrency it's a technology based
currency obviously the currency is based
on trust the only reason you can trade a
coin with the president's face on it or
a green piece of paper with the
president's face on it for goods or
services because the person taking it
knows they can trade it that's called
trust in the economy trust in the flow
of currency if suddenly we decided eight
and a half by eleven pieces of white
paper were the currency then everybody
would be willing to accept and I you
know a sheet of typing paper you know
like my notes are written on as payment
than you that would count if blue ink
pens or the thing that people started
accepting you would take that we value
diamonds we value gold but the only
reason we value them instead of gravel
out of your driveway is because of the
rarity and because there's this common
thread that says we're willing to accept
them and trade them and that's the only
reason Bitcoin will work I think it will
work long-term
I think it's gonna be okay before it
does it's going to break some of you
though because it's going to go down as
fast as it went up it may go up some
more before it does that but you're
gonna get to experience that he who
hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished
long before Bitcoin is stabilized and
made an integral part of the world
economy it is in the mania phase if it
survives and I kind of think it will
when I kind of hope it does I like the
concept I don't I'm not mad about it any
form of currency just fine I'll I'm in
Europe I use euros I don't mind on that
you know I use PayPal I use methods of
payment you know what do you think these
what do you think when we pay online it
is it's just digits moving I didn't send
you any green pieces of paper I just
sent you digits that represent green
pieces of paper so it's all digital
trade anyway these days but what it
where's the trust and we're gonna see so
here's what's gonna happen some of you
that are greedy and you're immature
children you're gonna lose a lot you'll
lose a lot for this is over I hope you
don't but you're going to see who
hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished there's the old man talking
we'll see how it turns out in five years
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show